so kamala harris once again creating
headaches for the administration things
getting heated between the vice
president
and a tv host by the name of charlemagne
the god after he asked this tough
question
so who's the real president of this
country is it joe manchin or joe biden
madam vice president come on charlemagne
i really don't it's joe buckley i can't
tell something else no no no no it's joe
biden and don't start talking like a
republican about asking whether or not
he's president do you think joe manchin
is a problem and it's joba and it's joe
biden and i'm vice president and my name
is kamala harris so so you have that
greg and there are other segments to
this interview
the best part
the best part you didn't even clip it
was when he looked over to the side he
goes oh they can hear me because they
claim that they didn't hear him the
thing is how bad is this when you're on
with charlemagne with simone sanders in
the control room and it's an inner and
you have the most benevolent situation
and it's still that bad that's why
she can't do other interviews i'm
getting the feeling that the dems want
an entire clean slate for 2024. it's
kind of like
when you after a car accident or when
your car gets stolen and it's returned
you just want the insurance company to
total the car you don't want to repair
the wreck you know it's like it's like
it's the car's just not the same anymore
even when they bring it into the shop
it's like still has that smell of after
whoever did what in the back seat now
you just want to get a new car that's
what the dems want total it
they need an insurance company to come
in and just you know dana what is he's
talking about simone sanders who's
leaving kamala harris's office the end
of this month and she's like 32. she was
saying we can't hear the question yes
right as caballeros was about to
answer the question yeah look i think
that um simone has done her best right
and she sets up an interview for kamala
harris that's going to be friendly and
they know that it's going to be i have a
different view about this i think that
this interview helped kamala harris with
the people she needs to
have more confidence in her and that's
their base midterms elections are not
about independent swing voters who show
up once in a while for a midterm these
are about base elections at the end of
the interview what charlemagne says is
that's the kamala i have missed that's
the kamala i want to see so i have a
feeling you're going to see a lot more
of that who knew that charlemagne the
god
was charlemagne the newsmaker i did
because this was not the first time he
was the one who had candidate joe biden
on when biden said if you don't vote for
me you ain't black this is this is where
people get wrong with charlotte first of
all he's a liberal and he's
he he tells people this but he holds
people accountable based on the things
they said they were going to do and that
was the purpose of this interview kamala
was not prepared she got very defensive
i i agree to a certain extent with dana
that it helped her at the end because he
gave her a piece of advice to say in the
future that's yeah uh they want to see
that prosecutor that was when the
republicans when you grill republicans
when the donald trump administration was
in there but she still didn't answer the
question first of all we know that
charlemagne wasn't suggesting that joe
biden was the president of the united
states the question was who has the most
power
which is mansion and she refused to
answer that question he also followed up
by saying uh it's mentioned a problem
she did not answer that question as well
and then she got into this whole thing
about her being the vp and and everyone
knows that and then she had a great
moment at the end where she was
aggressive and respect but there was no
substance there which is her problem she
has great moments when they can script
them out which we saw
at the early of the the campaign with
joe biden but when you start getting
into policy and where she stands on
thing and don't take my word for it look
at her people her people don't even
trust her to answer the question because
you clearly heard wow the question uh
degan uh the newly
boosted degan mcdowell how did you um
how did you hear the exchange there i
watched the whole thing twice
charlemagne was hand feeding the vice
president marshmallows
the entire interview he asked the same
question over and over and over again
and actually a good interviewer would
just move on rather than keep continuing
to bring up uh joe manchin joe manchin
joe manchin she went into a five-minute
soliloquy at the beginning of the
interview and then at the end just
repeated the exact same thing she had
said at the beginning
and
charlemagne kept asking
when are we going to get a real um get
real with the american people and know
that joe manchin is ruining the country
um he's stopping progress and ruining
democracy he just went on and on it the
whole thing was just a
shonda i do agree the first answer
went for a long time well and then the
end it was and by the way what the heck
was charlemagne even asking
why is joe manchin allowed to constantly
hold up president biden's agenda kamala
harris should have said you know she
actually had to give a poli-sci lesson
in the middle of the interview
does the president have the power to
force a duly elected member of the
senate to do his bidding no and on and
on it went uh in a moment here it could
be the rematch of the century this
century in fact what hillary clinton and
donald trump are saying
about
2024 what's next
[Music]
not again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for the gifts you won't forget
the mercedes-benz winter event
during the cold war the united states
developed the sr-71 blackbird and it's
still the fastest plane ever made it has
stood the test of time against all
challengers just like gold
hi i'm william devane and i buy gold
because it helps protect my assets
against out of control debt i buy gold
every chance i get from rosland capital
just as this plane evaded radar
gold helps my portfolio steer clear of
global chaos gold helps put me at the
controls of my own financial future if
this plane made you feel safer imagine
what owning gold can do
help preserve your wealth buying gold is
easy at rosland capital so ask yourself
are you safe call now for your free gold
silver and ira transfer kits call
800-630-8900
800-630-8900
that's
800-630-8900 when news breaks shannon
green delivers we've got a live report
with breaking details fox news at night
with shannon dream weeknights on fox
news channel america is watching
successful and driven pushing the limits
and claiming the rewards it's called
living the dream and you're doing it you
deserve comfort and relaxation it's time
to treat your senses to the new x-77
massage chair from chair luxuriate in a
relaxation so deep you'll lose yourself
in the moment the x-77 massage chair
puts therapist level technology and
touch quality at your command this
immersive experience was crafted by a
japanese shiatsu master you choose the
mode and let x77 take it from there from
kneading to tapping to stretching x77
will relax and rejuvenate tight tired
muscles from your glutes to your neck
your calves to your feet and your
shoulders to your hands we've got you
covered all the way down to your
fingertips this holiday season save a
thousand dollars on the new x77 massage
chair and get a free x chair with code
massage live the dream and buy now when
we started our business we're paying
like an arm and a leg for the postage i
remember sitting on ship station i think
it was just like one or two clicks
everything was up and running i was
printing out labels and saving money
ship station saves us so much time it
makes it really easy and seamless pick
an order print everything you need slap
the label onto the box and it's ready to
go our cost for shipping like work cut
in half just like that shipstation the
number one choice of online sellers go
to shipstation.com try and get two
months free
we're excited to do business with you
but before we sign i gotta ask sure
anything
we searched you online and
maybe you can explain this
can't believe that garbage is still
coming in that is so false frustrated
with your online search results call
reputation defender today to join tens
of thousands who've improved their
online reputation get your free
reputation report card at
reputationdefender.com
or call
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the 1-877-866-8555 that could
signal the end times donald trump and
hillary clinton in 2024
hillary clinton said that if you win
again it is the end of democracy
will this be a rematch
oh i have no idea i hope so i mean i'd
like that but but look the woman's
crooked as can be
i miss that
we don't deserve him and there's
speculation that hillary is gearing up
for another run after a new round of tv
appearances where she keeps throwing
jabs at trump
if i were a betting person right now i
say trump is going to run again this is
a make or break point are we going to
give in to all of this
all these lies and this disinformation
and this organized effort to undermine
our rule of law and our institutions are
we going to stand up to it i'm so happy
she finally brought up the russian
collusion hoax
you know you know degan it's this if you
follow the arc of a perfect story that
followed the script you know beginning
middle and end this is the end this is
exactly if if this were a simulation
this is exactly what we're supposed to
get
yes
we know she's running again because she
hot rolled her hair yes
that's what i do
southern women know it's like oh she's
broken out the hot curlers
um lots of questions about jeffrey
epstein if she decides to run again i
would greatly look forward to that in
addition to the russia collusion oaks
and the dossier and all of that but to
me this seems like a sequel
like battlefield earth 2 that nobody's
really asking for
i don't know i kind of want this you
know you know what here's the deal
lawrence fox doesn't need this we're
like huge we're the greatest cable news
network that will ever be but cnn and
msnbc need this oh yeah they need it
because they need the cnn is like about
a month away from closing up shop this
could save them uh this is another rocky
fight if you need it uh here's the deal
uh hillary is not over this
but so are the democratic voters they're
not over just in a different way the
thought of that election gives them ptsd
yeah and so i don't think that she would
be able to get the nomination because
she is the gut she's the person not the
guy she's the person that couldn't beat
donald trump and they'll be forever a
stain on her record she gives them ptsd
bill gives him
hammer
[Laughter]
don't we need new blood
i guess
i did the numbers though
trump would be 78
yes hillary would be 77. wow joe biden
to be 82 jesus kamala harris approval
rating as of last week was 28
i did a great gut felt for you yes
as greg would say if this were a fight
on the playground everyone would have a
black eye right trump is tied to january
6 and he lost to biden clinton lost to
trump and she lost to obama gavin newsom
faced down a recall but he has issues
coming out of the covid schools mandates
liberal state pete budajes is running
the supply chain but you have to go to
the port in california right yes it's
entirely possible but i agree with you
it would be really good for stable that
was good yes yes but you know what he
brought up gavin newsom which i think is
the is the four front runner and de
santa desantis could you imagine that as
the governor versus governor two
different approaches
first of all i'd like to go on the
record say that hot rollers were some of
the best inventions ever and i think
they should make a comeback secondly um
you said you earlier said you think the
democrats want a clean slate i think
that is true and i do not think that she
wipes the slate clean for the democrats
i think they would be dreading that the
other thing is that hillary clinton
can't catch a break she wanted to make
news on sunday about how she might put
her toe back in the water but guess what
joe manchin stole all her news on fox
news sunday there you go there you go by
the way i don't like it when you use
things that i've said in an earlier
block that contradicts what i say later
oh people aren't the blocks are
completely different so when i say they
want a clean slate but they want this
those are two separate
it's
so not fair hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else